the opinion is worthy and our
ratification process is ongoing I have
no doubt that it can be concluded on
time you spared no energy time or
commitment to clarify the issue or
explain what the withdrawal agreement is
and what it is not we left no stone
unturned
our mind has always been open our work
always creative and our hand as always
we always been outstretched it is in
this spirit that today the Prime
Minister and I have agreed on a joint
legally binding instrument relating to
the withdrawal agreement this instrument
provides meaningful clarifications and
legal guarantees on the nature the
vector of the backstop the backstop is
an insurance policy nothing more nothing
less
the intention is not for it to be used
like in every insurance policy and if it
were ever to be used it will never be a
trap the instrument which sets out these
details has legal force while fully
respecting the guidelines of the
European accounts the guidelines
European Council has unanimously agreed
it complements the withdrawal agreement
without reopening
the tea shock would be prepared to back
this approach in the interest of overall
in politics sometimes you get a second
chance it is what we do with the second
chance that counts because there will be
no third chance there will be no further
interpretation of the interpretations
and no further assurance is on the
reassurances if the feigning meaning
vote false to attach tomorrow let us
speak crystal-clear about the choice it
is distilled of works it might not
happen at all it means we get regain
control of our laws by ending the
jurisdiction of the European Court of
Justice in the UK regain control of our
borders by ending free movement regain
control of our money by ending vast on
your payments to the EU the end of the
Common Agricultural Policy and the
Common Fisheries Policy for British
farmers and fishermen an independent
trade policy and the deal sets us on
course for a good future relationship
with our friends and allies in the EU a
close economic partnership that is good
for business ongoing security
cooperation to keep our peoples safe the
deal honors the referendum result and is
good for both the UK and the EU having
an insurance policy to guarantee that
there will never be a hard border in
Northern Ireland is absolutely right it
honors the UK's solemn commitments in
the Belfast Good Friday Agreement but if
we ever have to use that insurance
policy it cannot become a permanent
arrangement and it is not the template
for our future relationship
today we have agreed them first to join
to instrument with comparable legal
weight to the withdrawal agreement will
guarantee that the EU cannot act with
the intent of applying the backstop
indefinitely if they do it can be
challenged through arbitration and if
they are found to be in breach the UK
can suspend the backstop it sets out a
number of commitments to enhance and
expedite the process of negotiating and
bringing into force the future
relationship and it makes a legal
commitment that the UK into the EU will
begin work immediately to replace the
backstop with alternative arrangements
by the end of December 2020 third
alongside the joint instrument of on the
withdrawal agreement the United Kingdom
government will make a unilateral
declaration that if the backstop comes
into use and discussions on our future
relationship break down so that there is
no prospect of subsequent agreement it
is the position of the United Kingdom
that there would be nothing to prevent
the UK instigating measures that would
ultimately discipline
MPs were clear that legal changes were
needed to the backstop today we have
secured legal changes now is the time to
come together to back this improved
brexit deal and to deliver on the
instruction of the British people